well September is a key month for the
new car market to change the plate at 67
and you know it is a considerable
concern that we've seen a 9.3 percent
decline in new car sales on the previous
year that's across all private fleet and
business cars and there's a number of
reasons behind that there's a lot of
political and economic uncertainty and
also a lot of uncertainty about the
government's air quality plans well
that's it I'm in the drop in diesel
sales 21 percent which is absolutely
shocking I mean do you feel that the
politicians have just declared war on
diesel well I think there's a lot of
consumer concern over diesel and they're
really there shouldn't be the latest new
euro-6 diesel cars are cleaner than ever
before in the government's air quality
plans they won't face any ban anywhere
across the UK and you won't be charged
anywhere across the UK for driving a
Euro 6 a diesel car so you know talk of
bans really undermines the new car
market and what we really need to do to
get the greatest environmental benefits
is promote these latest euro-6 of diesel
and petrol vehicles what about these
comments that Michael Gove made ray said
he wanted to see all petrol engines off
the roads by 2040 do you think that's
had a contributory effect well I think
there is a lot of confusion over air
quality I think what's clear is is in
2040 we'll be in a very different car
market conventional petrol and diesel
engines probably won't be there anyway
there'll be some sort of hybrid and
there'll be lots more electric but
what's clear is for the foreseeable
future and certainly for the you know
next decade or so petrol and diesel
vehicles are still going to be the
majority fuel type and consumers
shouldn't be concerned about buying
these latest Euro six vehicles what
about the rest of the year do you see
any signs of improvement
well we adjusted our forecast in the
summer to 2.54 million for the rest of
2017 and we hadn't anticipated quite the
decline that we've seen in September so
it may well be that that is adjusted
further for the rest of 2017 but we'll
have to see and that's why we're urging
Lee calling on government really to give
clarity around our future relationship
with Europe don't forget a lot of the
cars that we buy today are imported from
Europe
and it's essential that we understand
our future trading relationship which
will give confidence to consumers and
businesses to make major purchases so
how worried are manufacturers and
traders at the moment about the fact
that we have not yet started talking
about trade with the EU we're still
stuck in the preliminary negotiations
obviously it's a you know inevitably a
great concern for the UK automotive
sector we are very internationally
exposed eighty percent of what we
produce here in the UK is exported
overseas vast majority of cars bought
here in the UK are imported our supply
chain is heavily integrated within
Europe so we are very exposed we've
heard some welcome signs from government
in the last few months in terms of talk
of a transitional deal and is you know
the avoidance of any cliff edge which
would be the worst case scenario for our
sector I think what we need now is more
detail we need more detail on the future
customs arrangements on the frictionless
trade for our sector being in the single
market having frictionless trade being
in the customs union has been vital to
the success or Renaissance of the car
industry and we'll need to try and
safeguard and keep as many of those
conditions in the future to provide
preserve the industry